welcome to the david pakman show i'm
farin cousins and i'm going to be
sitting in for david for these next two
days we've got a lot to cover today of
course we've had
more from the january 6 committee we've
had more from the documentary film that
is now a central piece of evidence in
those hearings we're going to be talking
about all that plus marjorie taylor
green's week-long meltdown
among many other stories so let's jump
right into it
and i want to start by of course talking
about the january 6 hearings
and the big takeaway that i have had
from all of these hearings we have seen
so far everything that's come out of the
committee and pretty much anything
that's been revealed
since january 6th of 2021
is that had donald trump
had a more competent team working for
him
i think his coup
would have gone a lot differently and
not of course in a good way for the
united states
so think about this for a moment one of
the things we learned earlier this week
was that mark meadows was actually
actually offering state officials uh
free
maga stuff including autographed maga
gear
if officials were you know willing to
toss out their state's 2020 election
results
not exactly
a big selling point right
you know like hey we know it's
unconstitutional we know you're going to
have to break the law but
we're going to throw in a free hat how
does that sound right
nobody in their right mind is going to
take that offer
and then of course we have
mike lindell
who has been spearheading the efforts to
overturn the 2020 election results to
this very day
attorneys like sydney powell and john
eastman and rudy giuliani
all of this cast of just absolute
weirdos
working to overturn the 2020 election
and all of them in my opinion
equally incompetent
and that's the thing though
had any of these individuals
been switched out by somebody that maybe
actually knew what they were doing you
know somebody with a little bit of a
brain in their heads
trump could have succeeded
you know switch out sydney powell and
rudy giuliani
and substitute in bill barr
suddenly that becomes a lot scarier if
the attorney general of the united
states had gone along with this plan
he would have been able to use
the power of the doj there would have
been enough people inside the doj to try
to carry out these plans
think for a second if instead of mike
lindell going out there and selling this
to the public which hasn't gone very
well for him
what if it was karl rove instead
things would have been a lot different
rove is a master at messaging he's an
expert manipulator whereas of course
mike lindell just comes across as you
know
a bit of an unhinged kind of guy
he's the pillow man for god's sakes
but you switch out
any one of these little weirdos
for somebody with even a little bit of
competence a little bit of credibility
suddenly we're looking at a very
different scenario in the united states
today
and of course
therein lies the bigger problem for the
future
donald trump of course and all other
republicans who might be planning
something similar they've all learned
from these mistakes
right they know the kind of people that
they need to put in place
and how do we know that they've learned
from this
well you need to look no further than
steve bannon for more than a year now
ever since trump left office really on
his podcast steve bannon has been one of
the leading cheerleaders telling these
maga folks out here across the country
go run for office
go become a poll worker
run for secretary of state run for
governor
put yourselves in the position
to where this
you know the allegedly stolen 2020
election which wasn't stolen but put
yourself in the position
to where you can do something about it
in the future
the framework has been laid down
okay it's not in the planning phases the
the framework is there now
to a degree
maybe not to enough of a degree to
actually overturn election results but
they're getting close
and they could be a heck of a lot closer
after this year's midterms and it all
goes back to learning from their
mistakes
they knew
or they know now they didn't know at the
time but they know now
that the people they had running this
whole thing
were wholly incompetent
so you replace them with more competent
individuals you replace them with people
who know how to get things done you
replace them with loyal lap dogs who are
not gonna tell you no
that of course has been one of trump's
driving factors with his endorsements so
far in the primary season that's why he
tried so desperately to get brian kemp
and brad raffensberger out of the state
of georgia
because he wants people that would not
tell him no
if he were to ask them to break the law
and it's already happening
again not to not to the degree that he
would like to see it or that other
republicans would like to see it
but it is happening
they know where their weak links were in
2021 on january 6th
and more and more of them of course are
being exposed by these january 6
hearings
and they're not going to make the same
mistake twice
and again that to me is where the real
danger lies it's great that we're
exposing everything that happened that
has to be done
we also have to hold them criminally
accountable for it
but
we can't you know once this is over wipe
our hands like cool case closed we've
saved democracy no
that threat is still out there
and that again is kind of the underlying
theme
of these hearings
it's been the underlying theme also for
the record
of the judges overseeing the cases of
the capitol rioters
they have said that plenty of these
people
we've seen how they've been essentially
brainwashed
and we believe it can happen again we
believe these people are still dangerous
that's why a lot of the judges
overseeing these cases have been annoyed
when prosecutors you know reduce the
charges down to misdemeanors the judges
want to put these people in jail
because they're afraid it's going to
happen again
we're getting reports from the
department of homeland security
you know to expect violence another
report came out yesterday
warning of the increased risk of
violence here in the united states as we
head into the midterms and all of it
goes back to january 6 folks
every bit of it
is tied back to that
because all these people from trump
down to his supporters and everybody in
between
they learned from their mistakes
and it's unlikely that they would be
making those same mistakes again
but you know one person who doesn't ever
learn from their mistakes
jared kushner
according to a new report
from the new york times it turns out
that jared kushner was in fact the
individual who gave the green light to
alex holder's documentary crew to come
along and film the trump family starting
in september 2020 and of course as
everybody now knows this is the
documentary footage that has been
given over the raw footage
given over to the january 6 committee
they're actually you know
meeting with mr holder today behind
closed doors he's testifying he's going
through footage with them
they're having a grand old time
but we don't know exactly what's in this
footage except of course
for a little snippet that the new york
times gave us again
jared kushner set this up
because he thought it would be a good
quote legacy project
for the trump campaign of the trump
family
and based on the tiny bit of footage
that has been viewed
by the media
we know that ivanka trump
told the documentary crew
that she actually supported
her father's efforts
to overturn the election
now that's a bit of a different story
isn't it
because from everything we have seen
from her text messages with mark meadows
from her testimony in front of the
january 6 committee she didn't want
anything to do with this
she she wanted this to be over
i mean heck her and jared actually threw
a party on the evening of january 7th
the day after the capitol riot through a
big old dinner party
where according to reports nobody even
brought up what happened the day before
you know she washed her hands of it
acted like nope i was never a part of it
never wanted anything to do with it
never supported it bill barr and i had
conversations where we talked about yeah
this whole thing is stupid it didn't
happen trump even came out recently
attacked bill barr for allegedly
corrupting ivanka
because she was afraid of hurting his
feelings
so she just agreed with him
that the election wasn't stolen
and now it turns out that he may have
been right
because according to this footage again
it's been viewed by the new york times
ivanka came out in an interview with
this documentary crew from alex holder
and agreed with the attempts to overturn
the 2020 election
now again
she told the january 6 committee a
different story
and she testified to that under oath
so
yikes right
hmm
almost almost seems
not saying it is but i'm saying it seems
to me
like that may be a little bit of perjury
right
you you can't say one thing under oath
but then
say something else one of those things
is a lie
and if what you told congress is a lie
then uh oh
you may have some serious legal problems
on your hands there ivanka
but of course all the committee could
really do at that point is issue a
criminal referral
if they choose to go that route right i
mean they may even look at it and say
we'll just point it out to the public
how she's a big old liar and a hypocrite
and move on which
at this point you know who knows what
could happen because we don't know what
else is in that footage
but
that's what we do know so far
it's a tiny little snippet a tiny little
piece
of probably thousands of hours of
footage
and so far it looks pretty bad for the
trump family
how bad you ask
well
according to new reports
the new evidence that the january 6
committee has received
mostly of course through this alex
holder documentary footage
is so intense and so overwhelming
that they have now decided to postpone
the remainder of their televised hearing
so that they can digest
all of this new
information
all of this new evidence they're calling
it evidence
not just information
this is evidence folks
the use of that word of course legally
speaking
implies that there is something there
something there that the committee needs
something there that the committee can
use
to possibly go after more leads go after
more people call more witnesses
find new paths
which to investigate
they're not postponing these hearings
lightly either
they didn't just look at it and say okay
yeah you're going to push all this back
no no they understand how powerful these
hearings have been
right they know that the public is
watching them they know that it is
affecting public opinion donald trump's
unfavorability ratings have gone up
since these hearings began
more people say that yes he was involved
yes he should be criminally charged
that poll has basically flipped
since
these hearings began
so by postponing them
the committee has taken a big risk but
they believe the risk will be worth the
reward
and that of course is based on the
information they have seen thus far
from that documentary footage
so it's got to be something good it's
got to be more than just ivanka
contradicting herself possibly lying
under oath to the committee
there's got to be much more than that
for them to push these hearings back
couple days couple weeks we don't even
really know yet
but when they come back
they're going to show us what's in this
footage
and i'm expecting some pretty big
fireworks
we have to take a quick break again i am
farron cousins you can find me on
youtube at youtube.com slash the ring of
fire and youtube.com fair and balanced
and i'm across all social media twitter
instagram and facebook at farron
balanced this is the david pakman show
and we'll be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david today and tomorrow
and
let's talk a little bit more about the
january 6 hearings but
let's go a different approach right
we've talked about the hearings we've
talked about what's been uncovered
but one thing we need to talk about too
is the republican response
i mean obviously
we've had some pretty massive
revelations from these uh committee
hearings
so massive in fact that even some of the
folks on fox news
even fox news hosts
have come out and said this looks really
bad for trump
they have had paid fox news analysts on
the air this week
that have said
i believe you could hit trump with
criminal charges obstruction of congress
to be specific
so even the folks at fox news not all of
them not even a majority
but a couple of them
starting to see those cracks form
looking at what's happening and saying
uh-oh
this is pretty bad so if even fox news
is saying that you gotta assume the
republicans in congress
not the ones implicated in the schemes
but the other ones you know the regular
ones
certainly
they've been moved by what we've seen
right
well no or at least they're pretending
that they're not moved by anything that
we have seen
in fact a recent report from the hill
this week
kind of highlighted a bunch of different
republican responses to what we've seen
so far from the committee so let me read
you
some of these responses that these
republican senators these are all
senators this is what they told
uh reporters from the hill first up we
have senate minority leader whip
john thune not minority leader sorry
senate minority whip john thune
to the degree that there are any people
who haven't made up their minds or don't
have an opinion one way or the other
maybe something comes out of this that
changes that
but it just seems like right now it's
mostly rehashing ground
okay
remember that phrase by the way
senator shelly moore capito
from west virginia says
yeah they're significant
but i'm not sure it's going to change
anyone's mind
okay
then we have senator kevin cramer from
north dakota
who says
no one's ever said anything to me about
it back home
i don't know that i know anybody that's
watched it no one has ever brought it up
as an issue
riddle me this senator kramer
who was the last time you were back in
north dakota where he actually spoke to
constituents
they not lectured them not gave a speech
but actually you know maybe you walked
into a diner maybe you did a town hall
but but i would love to see evidence of
you actually talking to people and them
saying we haven't watched any of it
because i'm willing to bet that hasn't
actually happened has it
yeah that just seems like something you
probably didn't actually do
republican senator mike rounds from
south dakota
says he watched the first day of the
hearings in parts of the second day and
then he said
i think they did a very nice production
they spent their time efficiently but
they didn't tell me anything that i
didn't already know
so we're back to that theme right like
ah this is all old news everybody knows
all these things that happen come on hit
me with the good stuff they say
lisa murkowski
alaska
said that the panel is quote basically
saying this is a rehash of everything
out there
a rehash
it's the second time we've heard that
word from a republican senator
offering a response to what we've
learned
from these january 6 committee hearings
it's a rehash
it's old news they're all telling us the
same things we've heard all this before
play some new material
well okay
i first have to say it almost seems as
if all of these responses are somehow
coordinated right
yeah i'm fully
willing to bet republicans probably sent
out a memo that eventually will make its
way public telling republican senators
how to respond to all of this downplay
downplay downplay say that oh this is
nothing we didn't already know
but here's the thing
there is a lot of stuff we didn't
already know
there there's been a lot of new material
i mean sure i've watched these hearings
and a lot of it i do say like yes okay i
knew that i knew that
but here's the thing and this is what
these republican senators have to
understand as well and they do
understand let's be clear they
understand it they're pretending they
don't understand it
these hearings are not for me
in fact honestly these hearings probably
aren't for you either
if you're watching this
you're a daily consumer pretty much of
political news
you're up on the issues you understand
things you know these things
these hearings aren't for you
these hearings aren't for the
republicans in the senate these hearings
are for the millions upon millions upon
millions of americans who haven't paid
attention to any of this
and again you as a daily news consumer
probably think that that's weird right
that are there really people like that
folks the majority of america
doesn't consume any political news on a
daily basis
let me tell the story this way
the very first hearing
my wife was sitting right next to me on
the couch as we're watching this
she she had no interest in it and she's
a teacher so the day of the capital riot
she wasn't glued to the tv she's
teaching her class she didn't get to see
any of the footage
she wanted to actually leave say i don't
care about this i don't want to see it
but she ended up glued to the tv that
night
in shock
because she had never seen it
i'd seen the footage
i had read stories about the testimony
that they were playing
but she hadn't
and she was shocked
just absolutely floored
that all of this took place shocked at
the beatings
that we were seeing these rioters do
against police officers
that
is who these hearings are for
those people the people who yeah they
understand yeah january 6 i know
something happened it was bad
but they didn't quite understand it
because they're not daily political news
consumers
and again and i know that sounds weird
folks that yes there are people out
there
most people do not do this on a daily
basis
even fox news right on a good night
they're breaking what 3 million viewers
in prime time
seems like a lot right
it's less than one percent of the
population
you add in the people who watch
political news on youtube
msnbc cnn add all that together
maybe maybe
you got five percent of the us
population
maybe
consuming daily political news either
from conservative liberal or neutral
sources doesn't matter
90 to 95 percent of the country out
there isn't doing that
they may tune into the local news in the
evenings you know find out what's
happening in their community you know
local sports get the weather for
tomorrow and that's it
they wake up they shower they go to work
they come home they get the kids they
make dinner
they watch a sitcom they you know binge
some tv shows and they go to bed and
they do it all again the next day
those are the people that these hearings
are for and as far as we can tell those
are the people that these hearings are
reaching
so for these republicans to act like oh
it's no big deal there's nothing new it
may not be new to you
but there are millions of americans
who've never seen this and never heard
this and it is having a major impact
on how they feel about american politics
just remains to be seen of course
how big that impact is going to be
next time folks head to the ballot box
and
speaking of ballots
we got a new very interesting poll from
the state of new hampshire this week
according to this new new hampshire poll
for the republican 2024 presidential
primary in the
ever important state of new hampshire
just because it's an early state
ron desantis the authoritarian governor
here in my state of florida
is now ahead
of donald
trump
but he's not just ahead
that's not all that's happened here he
hasn't just taken a lead
he has closed a 25-point
gap between trump and desantis
desantis closed a 25-point gap between
the two that existed all the way back in
october of 2021.
back then trump had 48 uh 43 of the vote
desantis had 18
today
desantis has 39 percent
and trump is 37.
still within the margin of error so you
know
trump doesn't need to sound the alarm
bells just yet
but this is an early primary state
if desantis
enters this race
and outperforms trump
in these early states
trump's done
now
i have said many times on my own
programs desantis is far more dangerous
than donald trump right he has all the
same horrific policies but none of the
baggage
that makes him far more dangerous
he can endear himself
himself excuse me to the more moderate
republicans out there the people who may
look at trump and say no i'm not going
to do that again
they can look at desantis and say oh but
i'll do that
so let me explain the dangers here
over the last year and a half
everybody here on the left we've been
talking about all these horrific laws
that have been passed state by state by
state you know a ban on
books and critical race theory
up here an abortion ban over here
a transgender athlete ban there
transgender affirming care banned over
there
all of those things
have happened here in florida and then
some
you know you've got other states that
have done one or two of these things
florida's the only one that's done all
of them all of
them
not to mention the voter suppression not
to mention the piece of legislation that
allows you as a motorist to run down a
protester if they're standing in the
street and they're in your way and not
face any criminal charges
florida pioneered all this folks
we have all of the horrible pieces of
legislation
crammed into one state on top of that
our economy is in the absolute toilet
right now
one of the most unaffordable states to
live in now our housing prices have
risen faster than any other state in
this country under ron desantis and he
has done all of this
tanked our economy and of course passed
all this massively oppressive
legislation
in three years
in fact almost all of it was actually
passed within the last 18 months
he did all of this damage rose to
national prominence
in 18
months
folks
just imagine what he could do with four
years in the white house
now personally
i don't know that desantis would do well
on a republican debate stage the guy
gets very flustered very easily he loses
his temper he gets you know kind of
flustered the way marco rubio did back
in the 2015 debates which was hilarious
to watch
so i don't know that desantis could
actually survive that but if he did he
may be a shoe-in
and he would be very difficult for any
democrat to beat definitely difficult
for any republican to beat
because as as horrible as this
legislation is as bad as some of the
things he said are
he doesn't have any real
scandals you know there's no real
skeletons in the closet he's just a bad
guy
and unfortunately a lot of this
legislation that we look at as just
absolutely repulsive and oppressive
most people do support a lot of it not
all of it but a lot of it
that's the worst part
it's not turning off enough people
so desantis finally pulling ahead of
trump in the state of new hampshire
that's bad
it's not bad for you know trump really
it's bad for the united states
we have to take another break again i am
fair and cousins find me on youtube
youtube.com slash the ring of fire and
youtube.com fair and balanced and i also
host the weekly ring of fire podcast you
can check that out for free or you can
become a member if you'd like
at
rofpodcast.com again i'm fair and
cousins in for david pakman and we'll be
right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com davidpakmanshow where
you can get access to behind the scenes
videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show welcome back to the
david pakman show i am fair and cousins
from ring of fire
let's get back into some of the news of
the week and
one of the more interesting non-january
six things that have happened this week
is that marjorie taylor greene
has been suffering basically a week-long
meltdown
for so very many different reasons
the first of course is the fact that it
was recently revealed that the
individual
that has been
defacing her uh transphobic sign outside
of her office turns out to be the chief
of staff to a democratic representative
and the capitol police were able to find
this individual they put up you know
security cameras they got him on camera
they referred him for criminal
prosecution and the doj said yeah we're
not going to go after that
which honestly makes a lot of sense
this individual sure i mean nobody
should deface property
make sure i'm crystal clear on that
don't do it
but
it's always a but
um
you know writing on somebody's sign like
writing bible verses putting stickers on
it is what they did um
you really want to criminally prosecute
somebody for that
i mean you're talking about
a misdemeanor offense
you know the value of which is far less
than anything that could even remotely
send somebody to jail
so you're mostly talking maybe giving
them probation maybe community service
maybe again we're talking about a very
minor misdemeanor probably just a fine
and marjorie taylor green is you know
basically crying every day because the
doj doesn't want to spend thousands of
dollars to prosecute somebody
for putting a couple stickers on her
sign
and of course she's mad about triumph
the insult comic dog colbert's staff you
know going in and
mocking her
and so she was given some time this week
on the floor of the house
which i don't know why she was given the
time but she was given the time and she
used it to paint herself as the biggest
victim
that the united states has ever seen
here it is take a look at marjorie
taylor green talking about how she is
being viciously attacked on all fronts
here it is i have come here as a
freshman member of congress and i want
to remind everyone i've never been
arrested i've always paid my taxes i
have not broken the law
i've done nothing wrong it's the
majority party that doesn't like my
speech that's it
so i've been kicked off committees i've
been routinely attacked
i have been lied about my character has
been completely destroyed not only by
people in here but the media definitely
helps them
now that was just a 32 second clip
of representative green speaking on the
house floor about all these horrible
things she spoke for an hour
whining about how mistreated she has
been she spent more than 10 minutes of
that hour
talking about her poor little signs
and of course she claims that she was
attacked because the member of congress
across the hall put out a uh
you know lgbtq flag i think i think it
was actually the transgender flag
so that was an attack on her
so she had to fight back by putting her
little transphobic sign out there fo
she's just fighting back
i got no sympathy
for marjorie taylor green you have not
actually been attacked you've been
mocked you've been ridiculed sure but
you deserved every second of it
you want to talk about actual attacks
how about we talk about how you have
treated david hogg the parkland survivor
how you repeatedly harassed him
are you still to this day harass him on
twitter
luckily
that young man is far more mature than
marjorie taylor greene could ever hope
to be how about before you even came
into office when you were essentially
stalking
representative aoc
are you yelling through her mail slot in
her office
there's been reports of you of course
walking down the hallway screaming at
democratic members of congress you know
we saw you the one time democrats doing
the press conference on the steps of the
capitol you came out and you started
screaming at them
those are attacks
and you have the audacity to sit there
on the floor of the house of
representatives
and whine about
a puppet
a puppet triumph insult comic dog is a
puppet
and you were triggered by the little
puppet it made you sad
and then of course your sign your poor
little sign oh you have to keep sending
your staffers over to fedex to make a
new sign oh dear me
how do you even get up in the morning
marjorie my goodness
maybe take yourself down off of that
cross for a minute
and look in a mirror
you want to know why people are are
horrible to you as you say
it's because you get back what you put
in
you have done nothing
to improve the lives of anyone in this
country
you have never shown anyone any kind of
basic niceties
you have been mean you have been a bully
i mean heck you put out a video one time
you were in the middle of a workout you
stopped halfway through pulled out your
camera just to do a short video telling
joe biden he was a piece of you know
excrement and then you went back to your
workout that's not even normal behavior
like that just goes beyond bullying to
where
i would say that's almost a symptom in
my opinion
but you can't treat the entire world
like garbage
and then get mad when people dish it
back out to you
if you're gonna deliver it you better
learn how to take it
or better yet
maybe try being a decent human being for
a few minutes each day see how that
works out for you
but honestly
i don't think you have it in you
and speaking of bullies how about we go
over to lauren bobert right now
lauren bobert this week sent a letter to
transportation secretary pete buttige
begging him for 33 million dollars to
construct a new bridge in her district a
new bridge that she says
is going to help with evacuations it's
going to help with emergency vehicles
because you know colorado
has a lot of wildfires
and bobert says look we get you got this
money from the infrastructure bill we
would love for you to you know come and
spend this 33 million dollars on a new
bridge people need it people could die
without it honestly all good points
right
but the irony here of course
is that lauren bobert
has spent the last year
mocking
pete buddha judge's sexuality
you know when he took paternity leave
she went on
national media and said he's probably
learning how to chest feed
you've mocked his husband
you've mocked everything about this man
you have blamed him for things that are
not even his fault
and now you have the audacity
to look up to him and say hey
how about 33 million over here for a new
bridge from my district so i don't you
know
get creamed in my election i kind of
need to do something for these people
because i've done nothing
so would you help me out
now
i will say
she should not be punished
just because she is a horrible person
now
rephrase that her constituents should
not be punished just because they sent a
horrible person to congress
they have the opportunity to write that
wrong actually i think it's coming up
next week right they got that primary
don coram the republican running against
her you've got democrats
that have switched from being democrats
to registered either independents or
republicans so they can go vote against
lauren bobert in that primary like there
is this massive concerted effort to get
this individual out of office
and it's because she's a horrible person
and for the republicans
in her district
it's because she's completely
ineffective
that's why she's sending this last
minute pitch to bootage
you know that's why she's pretending
that she hasn't spent the last year
basically calling him a horrible person
because he's not a straight white man
she needs that 33 million dollar bridge
to be able to show her constituents yes
i may do crazy things sometimes but hey
look i delivered for you
and unfortunately they do need the
bridge
and i personally do not believe
in abusing political power
you know just to make an individual pay
you know just to punish a political
rival that's not okay
you know just ask chris christie and
bridgegate
something everybody forgot about a
scandal that honestly today probably
wouldn't even be a scandal
considering the scandals we see these
days
but again
it's the same thing with marjorie taylor
green you can't spend your whole life
just being a horrible person to
everybody you come in contact with
and then expect them to be nice to you
this is basic you know growing up type
stuff your mothers your fathers anybody
any kind of you know adult figure in
your life should have taught you this
when you were young children
you get back what you put in i know my
mother told me that a million times
she'll still tell me that to this day
and that's not saying that you have to
sit there and suffer the slings and
arrows of everyone coming after you
you can stand up for yourself absolutely
but there's a difference between
standing up for yourself and being an
outright bully which is what people like
lauren bobert and marjorie taylor green
have become
and
here's another issue
we talk about marjory taylor green we
talk about lauren bobert you know you're
matt gates as you jim jordans all of
these little extremists
out there serving in congress today
they're dangerous individuals
and they're individuals who after this
year's midterms
might have even more power which is even
scarier
but
right now
according to a report from the new
republic you have democratic groups
including by the way nancy pelosi's
majority political action committee that
are actually out there in this country
running ads
trying to promote
extremist republican candidates because
they somehow think that if we promote
the extremists and then they get on the
primary or they make it past the primary
get on the general ballot then hey
that's going to drive people to the
democrats right
because that worked so well
in 2016 when when the democratic party
promoted trump
because they thought he'd be the easiest
to beat
and for the record technically you know
popular vote hillary clinton did beat
him
but we don't go by popular vote we go by
electoral college
so that doesn't mean a whole heck of a
lot
the problem is these democratic groups
are playing with fire
the problem is the democrats don't
understand
that the republican party doesn't view
these people as extremists
they buy into the whole oh no they're
just an outsider the swamp is coming
after them because they're out there
draining it
oh they're the true fighters they're the
ones out there spreading the truth and
fighting for us
they're saying the things the other
folks are too scared to say that's how
republicans view these people that's why
they they get elected in office in the
first place
yes every now and then some of them are
like hey we were duped we're not making
that mistake again
see also madison cawthorne
but we had to have madison cawthorne in
congress before the people who voted for
him realized how bad he was
and we could be looking at a similar
situation in these areas where the
democrats are promoting the extremist
candidates it's a stupid strategy let's
be honest let's call it what it is it's
stupid
it's something that hasn't worked for
the democrats in the past and of course
it ignores the fact that most
republicans actually like what these
people have to say they support these
policies only 21 percent of republicans
in recent polling said they believe
biden legitimately won the election only
20 percent of
them they believe the craziness
so maybe the best strategy is not to
promote these people
but to remind the voters
that these extremists
aren't living in a little place that we
like to call
reality
we gotta take another quick break again
i'm fair and cousins find me on youtube
at youtube.com slash the ring of fire
and youtube.com
farron balanced i'm on twitter instagram
and facebook at farron balanced
sitting in for david pakman we'll be
right back with more from the david
pakman show
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
welcome back to the david pakman show
i'm farron cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david today and tomorrow
well we also have to talk you know we've
talked a lot about republican extremists
we've talked january 6 donald trump all
of that
we got to get to some issues here folks
and of course one of the biggest issues
facing americans today
is inflation
you know whether it's gas prices or
goods services everything out there
inflation is absolutely crippling
the united states economy
and according to a new report from the
roosevelt institute
a lot of this uh
if inflation if you want to call it that
is actually rooted in nothing more than
corporate greed
now that's not to say that inflation is
not happening right now at a staggering
and alarming rate it is
but it's happening all over the world
not just here in the united states
this is not a u.s problem this is a
global supply issue
but here in the united states we do have
something a little bit unique
we have what is being called now greed
flation
and that greed flation is corporations
of course jacking up prices beyond
what inflation is forcing them to pay
and passing that on to consumers
it's a very simple scam and to be honest
corporations many ceos executives
they've actually admitted to doing this
in interviews over the past year
they have said on the record that times
of high inflation are the perfect time
for companies to raise their prices
anyway
one because they don't get blamed for it
but two inflation eventually goes away
you know sometimes it lasts a little
longer you know but
eventually the prices will go back down
and when people start seeing the price
tags go back down they get happy they're
like oh boy it's over
and then eventually the price will
settle somewhere that will be more than
what it was before the period of
inflation but lower than what it was
with inflation so consumers think they
win
but that difference between the
pre-inflation price and the
post-inflation price
that
is the corporate price gouging
and again this new report from the
roosevelt institute says that corporate
price gouging right now
based on profits
based on what they're paying these
corporations
with inflation and then passing on to
consumers is the worst level it has been
in the united states since the 1950s
so it's been roughly 70 years most
people alive today
have never seen corporate price gouging
as bad as it is and of course this was
just for the year 2021
because we don't have final numbers from
2022 because we're only halfway through
the year
so this report was only looking at last
year
when inflation and price gouging was not
as bad as it has been so far this year
if you want to know a good example look
at tyson foods tyson foods recently
released you know their their quarterly
report
in their quarterly report
they showed that inflation had caused
their
costs
to go up i'm just going to make up
numbers because i don't remember exactly
but i do remember the percentages so
trust me
let's say their cost went up 1.5 billion
but the prices they raised for consumers
wasn't 1.5 billion it was 2 billion
so there's a 500 million dollar gap in
there that is nothing more
than corporate greed raising prices
simply for the fact that they can
and again those weren't the exact
numbers but it was the correct
percentages there was a 25
increase so
what we're looking at is a time when the
united states more than ever
needs a windfall profit tax
on these corporations whether it's the
oil industry
whether it's the grocery stores
manufacturers
car manufacturers doesn't matter
a windfall profits tax
could put an end to this corporate price
gouging that is crushing americans every
time they go shopping doesn't matter
what they go shopping for
and believe it or not this corporate
windfall profit tax is now supported by
a majority
of american citizens a majority of them
want this windfall profits tax
it's a simple solution
it's a simple solution to a growing
problem that affects the wallets of
everybody in this country rich and poor
alike
it obviously affects the poor a lot more
than it affects the rich
but everybody's paying higher prices
the windfall profits tax
could put an end to that
we just have to have legislators with
the courage to actually do this
and unfortunately we do not have enough
of them
instead we get ideas from biden like
coming out this week like oh what about
a gas tax holiday cool you're going to
save the average american family three
dollars and sixty cents a week
those are the numbers folks three
dollars and sixty cents a week is what
you would probably end up saving on
average the average family actually
if you fill up your tank once a week and
you got a 20 gallon tank
that three dollars and sixty cents isn't
gonna change your life at all
honestly it's not even gonna help you
i'm sorry but it's not you can't even
buy a gallon of milk with that because
of inflation and corporate price gouging
so that's a bad idea especially because
that money's actually used to fund
infrastructure and hey we're already
having trouble spending our
infrastructure bill money because of
inflation
so all those infrastructure projects
that we were promised they've been put
on hold because the prices are so dang
high
we're just getting screwed every which
way you look at it
and all of it comes right back to that
issue of corporate greed
but don't worry it's not just major
corporations that are guilty of greed
here in the united states congress has a
very serious problem
with using their insider knowledge
to buy and sell stocks
we have seen the reports you know a
business insider earlier this year maybe
even early last year whatever it was 64
members of congress in the last two
years have violated the stock act
almost 200 of their staffers have also
violated the stock act
and of course these individuals have
information
they've got budget information they know
where money is going to be spent before
it gets spent
and they can use this information
to buy stocks they can use it to sell
stocks
and a majority of americans 70 percent
of them to be exact
say they want a ban on congressional
stock trading
50 of republicans and 45 percent of
democrats say they're actually going to
be more likely to vote for a candidate
if they support a ban on politicians
trading stocks
i
personally you may think it's a little
extreme
i want to go further than just banning
them buying and selling stocks
i don't think they should be allowed to
own them
sorry
again that's just me you can disagree
that's fine doesn't matter doesn't
bother me
but you're choosing a life of public
service
you've got to give those things up they
made jimmy carter sell his peanut farm
now if he had to sell his peanut farm i
don't think it's too far-fetched to say
that members of congress should have to
sell their raytheon stock
not a blind trust i want it banned they
can't own it at all
but i would also settle if this is the
best case scenario with a ban on them
buying and selling it
and so would of course 70
of the american public and the biggest
problem is this stock act that all these
congress people keep violating democrats
and republicans alike it's a bipartisan
issue
you know what the penalty is for
violating it
two hundred dollar fine
if the fine is even
you know put in place sometimes they
waive the fine
so you could trade fifty thousand
dollars worth of stock
you could buy fifty thousand you know
profit ten twenty thirty percent
whatever it is
you can make ten twenty thirty thousand
dollars off of it
and the only penalty you have is a two
hundred dollar fine
for violating the stock act at that
point that's not a fine
that's just a fee for doing business
listen that's all the time we have for
today's show we've got some great stuff
coming up in today's bonus show
including a republican who has been
removed from office for killing a man
i'm farren cousins find me at
youtube.com the ring of fire youtube.com
fair and balanced
thank you for watching and of course
stay tuned for the bonus show